Okay Michael, you got answers for me?
>> Yeah, I think so. The first thing I notice is that if I put
equal weights on all four examples, like
I, I decided that instead of solving this
problem by thinking, I would just try a couple examples, and see if I found
things in both boxes. So, if I put equal weight on X1, X2, X3, X4.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Then hypothesis one, H1 gets three
out of four correct, that's three quarters.
That's better than a half. So.
>> Well done.
>> Then I fill that in, in the good boxes, quarters all the way down.
>> That's a turtle, 'because it's turtles all the way down [LAUGH].
>> No, no, it's not though, it should be quarters all
the way down. I thought you'd may be draw a quarter.
>> I, I can't draw a quarter, also I can't draw a turtle obviously but still.
>> [LAUGH] Agreed. Alright, good.
>> You'd think, anyone, do you think anyone listening to
this is old enough to get turtles all the way down.
>> Yeah, that's a great joke. Everybody knows that joke.
>> And
if people don't know the joke, then we should pause this thing right now, and
you should go look up turtles all the way down. And then come back. Okay.
>> It's a, it's a really great joke if you're computer scientist.
>> Yes, and if you don't think it's a good
joke then you should probably be in a different field. Okay.
>> [LAUGH]
>> What about the evil distribution?
>> So then I started to generate. Okay, well what
if, the, the, the issue here is that, because we spread
all the, the, the, the probability out in the first hypothesis
really good. So I said okay, well let me put all
the weight on the first example. The x1.
>> Okay. So what did that look like.
>> Now h1 did very badly. It gets, it's 100 percent error. And
h2 is 100 percent error. But h3 is 0 percent errors. So so.
>> yes.
>> So, so putting it all putting all the weight on x1 is no
good. And if you look x2, x3, x4, they all have the property that there's
always a hypothesis that gets them right.
So I started to think, well maybe there
isn't an evil distribution. And I kind of lucked into putting a half on both
the first and the second one. because i figured that, that
ought to work, but then i realized, oh wait a second that's
an evil distribution, because if you choose h1, h2, or h3,
they all have exactly 50% error on the half a half distribution.
>> Very good. So 1/2, 1/2, zero, zero, is a correct answer.
>> Now I don't know if there's others. You know, certainly X, putting all
the weight on X2 and X3 is no good, because H2 and H1
both get those. Putting all the weight on X3 and X4 are no
good, because H1 gets all of those correct. In fact we have to
have some weight on X1, right. Otherwise H1 is the way to go.
>> Right. So, yeah. No, that's interesting.
So what does that mean in this case?
>> What do you mean, what does that mean?
>> So what does this tell us about, how
do we build a weak learner for this example?
>> So what it
tells us is that since there is a
distribution for which none of these hypotheses will
be better than chance, there is no weak
learner for this hypothesis space, on this instant set.
>> Interesting. Now is there a way that
we can, like, okay, so this example has no
weak learner. Is there a way to change
this example so it would have a weak learner?
>> Um...I'm sure there is.
>> Like if we change that x2, x, h3, if that was a check instead of an X.
>> Which one?
X2 H3.
>> So if we made that a green one, here I'll,
I'll make it a green one. By using the power of computers.
>> Woah, special effect.
>> Yes.
>> So now there's no way to put weight
on any two things and have it fail. I don't
know, my intuition now is that this, this should have
a weak learner. Okay, well, how would we prove that?
>> I don't know, but may be we should end this quiz.
>> Yeah, I think, we should end this quiz. And leave it as an exercise
to the listener. I'm pretty sure I can figure this out.
By the way, we should point a couple of things here
though, Michael. That one is that, the if it weren't the
case, if we had more hypotheses and more examples. Perhaps an odd
number of them and we have the x's and the y's
in the right places then there'd be lots of ways to
get weak learners for all the distributions just because you'd have
more choices to choose from. What made this one particularly hard is
that you only had three hypotheses and none of
them was, not all of them were particularly good.
>> Sure, yeah. I mean if you have a bun-, you can have many,
many hypotheses and they're all pretty bad
then you're not going to do very well.
>> Well, it would depend upon if
they're bad on very different things. But you're
right, if you have a whole lot of hypotheses that are bad at everything, you're
going to have a very hard time with a weak learner. And if you have a
whole bunch of hypotheses that are good at
almost everything, then it's pretty easy to have
a weak learner.
>> Interesting. Okay, this is more subtle
than I thought. So that's, that's interesting.
>> Right. So what the lesson you should take away
from this is. If you were just, to think about it
for 2 seconds you might think okay weak learner. That
seems easy. And often it is, but if you think about
for 4 seconds you realize that's actually a pretty strong
condition. You're going to have to have a lot of hypotheses that
are, many of which are going to have to do good on
lots of different examples, or otherwise, you're not always going to be
able to find one that does well no matter what the
distribution is. So it's actually a fairly strong, and important condition.